j'ai fait tomber un stylo sur mon
t-shirt juste avant de tourner je serai
d'horreur va vous plaire peut-être plus
que les autres pour certains d'entre
vous pourquoi parce que j'ai repéré une
petite frustration du côté de certaines
personnes qui en ont marre que ça se
finisse par l'individu n'a pas été
retrouvé on sait pas ce qu'il allait
faire on sait pas pourquoi il avait visé
cette personne saf russe certains parmi
vous je comprends mais il faut aussi
comprendre que si les personnes sont là
pour raconter leur histoire c'est que ça
s'est plutôt bien passé
et si ça s'est plutôt bien passé c'est
que la personne qui était menaçante à
dégager sans forcément se faire prendre
dans les trois histoires que je vous
racontais à la fin il y aura des
précisions c'est à dire qu'on sait qui
est l'agresseur on sait pourquoi il a
fait ça qui il était voilà je fais ça
comme ça les 4 5% qui était un peu
frustrés ils le sont plus y passer un
bon été ils sont ravis la première
histoire c'est celle de aymeric aymeric
nous explique qu'après lycée il ya déjà
quelques années de ça au moment où il
raconte l'histoire il était dans une
vieille passe sa tutrice avait expulsé
juste après qu'il ait obtenu son diplôme
et il s'est retrouvé sans logement il a
donc dû dormir pendant plusieurs mois
dans sa voiture et un jour il fait la
rencontre d'un groupe de fans de heavy
metal c'est pas des inconnus c'est des
gens qui sont plutôt connus en ville
c'est à dire que tous les amis d'aymeric
ça avait de plus ou moins loin qui
étaient ces gens est globalement tout le
monde l'est qui fait c'est des mecs
sympas bon délire bref le feeling passe
bien entre eux et aymeric à tel point
qu'il lui propose d'emménager avec eux
je vous rappelle qu'emeric à ce
moment-là il vit dans sa voiture donc
autant vous dire que c'est une très
bonne nouvelle pour lui sur place il ya
plusieurs colocataire et aymeric se
rapproche de deux frères en particulier
andrew et 7
andrew et 7 c'est des gens qui croient à
l'occultisme et à ce genre de truc alors
aymeric lui c'est pas son délire mais
bon il se dit qui je suis pour juger les
croyances des gens et en plus de ça ces
mecs là viennent de m'offrir un toit
gratuitement je m'en bats les couilles
de leurs croyances
il faut savoir qu'andrew et 7 sont très
proches d'un autre groupe de frères qui
connaissent depuis l'école et qui sont
devenus de très bons amis à eux qui dit
très bon ami dit beaucoup de passage
dans l'appartement dont la colocation à
tel point que cet autre groupe de frères
fait limite partie des colocataires dans
cet autre groupe de frères il ya le
frère cadet marc un mec très polis qui
nettoie toujours derrière lui qui
contribuent aux tâches ménagères
bref il est méga stable mais on peut pas
en dire autant du petit frère de marc
adam adam il a beaucoup de problèmes
psychologiques et se serait apparemment
liée à la prise d'une très mauvaise
drogue
il ya des années de ça il aurait peu à
peu développé une sorte de psychose
religieuse et il aurait même fait de la
prison pour avoir frappé une femme avec
une
bible sympa le madame invitez le à vos
adversaires aymeric explique adam c'est
le genre de gars qui des fois tu regarde
dans les yeux et tu te dis qu'il arrive
à voir comment tu vas mourir bonne
ambiance
il a même une fois 10 am rique qu' il
pouvait voir que son âme était possédée
par un démon et qu'il fallait qu'il la
purifie c'est qu'on jury voilà bref dans
la colocation tout le monde a bien
conscience des problèmes d' adam et tout
le monde est bienveillant et tout le
monde est ami avec lui et veulent tirer
vers le haut mais malgré tout ça il
mérite lui il est pas rassuré quand même
il se dit attentats
ce gars là il ya un truc chelou tout le
monde a l'air vraiment serein vis-à-vis
de lui moi je vais quand même une petite
distance une petite méfiance bref un
beau jour aymeric est en train de dormir
et son téléphone sonne
il décroche surprise c'est son patron
qui lui demande exceptionnellement de
venir au travail
une heure plus tôt à midi au lieu de 13
heures aymeric il est fauché il a
absolument rien eu à faire du coup il
est ravi c'est l'effet leurs deux taffes
payer en plus
il y va avant de partir ils passent dans
le salon pour voir marc andreu et adam
qui sont tous les trois devant la télé
en train de regarder youtube
aymeric leur dire au revoir et il part
au travail quelques heures plus tard en
fin d'après-midi henrique toujours au
travail il a bientôt fini 16 heures et
le téléphone sonne c'est son patron qui
répondent au téléphone et qui rapidement
lui tant l'appareil en lui disant c'est
pour toi aymeric prend le téléphone est
malheureusement c'est pas la voie d'un
ami au bout du fil c'est la voix de
l'inspecteur williams et cet inspecteur
et lui explique qui s'est passé un truc
dans son appartement et qu'il a besoin
qu'ils méritent viennent rapidement au
poste pour en discuter avec eux aymeric
qui tout de suite son travail et se dit
ils ont dû faire de la merde avec
de la drogue ils ont dû essayer d'en
vendre ils sont fait choper relou en
arrivant au poste il ya un agent qui
vient tout de suite cherché emeric et
qui l'amène dans une pièce avec une
caméra il isole et il le laisse ici tout
seul pendant 30 minutes
généralement quand arrive au
commissariat et que tout de suite on
s'isole comme ça c'est qu'il se passe un
truc vraiment pas ouf
trente minutes plus tard l'inspecteur
williams entre dans la salle ça soit et
expliqué emeric que adam a poignardés et
tués
andrew aux alentours de 13 heures c'est
à dire seulement une heure après
qu'henrik soit parti au travail
aymeric évidemment il est choqué
demandent plein d'infos aux policiers
qui lui disent que malheureusement ils
ont le droit de rien lui dire puisqu'une
enquête est en cours et qui peuvent pas
dévoiler des éléments au cours des deux
jours suivants il ya des infos qui
commence à circuler et ses lacs aymeric
comprend ce qui s'est passé ce jour là
aux alentours de 13 heures adam se jette
sur rendez vous
il met pas un coup de couteau il lui en
mai des dizaines juste après ça ils
courent sur la route en face de leur
appart toujours l'arme du crime en main
et il appelle la police pour
immédiatement leur dire ce qu'il veut
faire
évidemment la police a débarqué
extrêmement rapidement sur les lieux
elle a arrêté
adam et elle a aussi perquisitionné le
domicile parmi les objets trouvés se
trouve un cahier dans lequel adam avait
écrit qu'il comptait tuer tous les co
locataire de l'appartement
y compris ses propres frères et y
compris évidemment aymeric parce qu'ils
sont apparemment tous possédés par des
démons et que ce serait le seul moyen de
les libérer
heureusement ce jour là dans
l'appartement il y avait que mark et
andrew qui était avec adam et marque a
réussi à s'échapper à la seconde où adam
s'est jeté sur andrew avec le couteau et
surtout heureusement ce jour là le
patron d'aymeric l'a appelé pour le
faire venir au travail
une heure plus tôt sinon il aurait
totalement était dans l'appartement au
moment des faits et qui sait comment ça
aurait fini
est ce que c'est bon pour vous quel
enfer vous êtes serein les gens en
colocation qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
adam qui débarque
aymeric explique plus tard qu'il est
profondément triste qu'à l'époque tout
le monde est un peu normalisée est
sous-estimé les problèmes psychologiques
de adam et que peut-être que tout ça
aurait pu être évité s'il avait fait
suivre s'ils lui avaient apporté un vrai
soutien de la part de professionnels
n'est pas juste un soutien amical
bref ça m'a foutu le cafard on passe à
la deuxième histoire la deuxième
histoire c'est celle de jane et
accrochez-vous parce qu'elle est un peu
longue à l'époque jane est à
l'université et dès qu'elle arrive aux
abords du bâtiment elle donne une pièce
à wendell un sans abri qui est tout le
temps
posté au même endroit elle explique que
manière générale c'est pas trop son
genre de donner de l'argent à un inconnu
a préfère plutôt donner de l'argent à
des organisations caritatives ou à des
associations mais elle explique que
wendell y chante de l'opéra et elle ça
la touche - dell il est plutôt attachant
il aime faire rire les élèves avec des
blagues d'imitation engine même les
jours et là pas de monnaie elle prend le
temps d'échangés de 3 mois avec lui
parce qu'il est vraiment sympathique
un jour par exemple il lui a expliqué
qu'il avait failli aller à l'université
avec une bourse de baseball mais comme
il était accro aux drogues c'est tombé à
l'eau
un jour jane base devant wendell
accompagné d'un professeur wendell
interpelle jane pour échanger deux trois
phrases et donc jane lui présente un
tueur helmand son professeur après
s'être échangé quelques phrases jane et
son prof continuent leur chemin et son
propre regard jane en lui disant
pourquoi ce gars connaissait ton prénom
et jane lui explique que ils se parlent
quelquefois que des fois elle lui donne
de l'argent qu elle en a et que le gars
est attachant écoulé que tout va bien
mais juste avant que leurs chemins se
séparent le professeur
east il expliqua jane qu'elle ne devrait
pas nouer des liens d'amitié avec les
sans abri de cette ville ni leur donner
d'argent puisqu'ils ont très souvent
tendance à avoir des antécédents
criminels ou de dépendance la jane c'est
son esprit de contradiction qui se met
en route elle est absolument pas
d'accord avec son professeur elle le
trouve totalement radical dans sa
manière de penser et elle se dit que
elle va prouver à son professeur qu'il a
tort en allant encore plus parler à
wendell et en prouvant encore plus à la
terre entière que c'est un gars
sympathique qui méritent pas ce qui lui
arrive sauf que le lendemain quand j'ai
une passe devant wendell c'est pas comme
d'habitude
wendell il est distant il est aigri elle
comprend pas pourquoi jusqu'à ce qu'ils
lui disent alors ton petit ami ça se
passe bien
elle comprend tout de suite qui fait
référence à son professeur et lui
explique n'hésitez pas son petit ami
c'est son professeur est immédiatement
wendell n'est plus aigris les nouveaux
bavard il fait même des petites blagues
bref le temps passe et wendell commence
régulièrement à offrir des petits
cadeaux à jane quand il passe devant lui
ce genre des jetons de supermarchés des
fleurs à tel point que le professeur de
jane va le remarquer et va décider de
lui en parler et lui explique qu'elle
est en train de se faire manipuler et
cette fois pour la première fois jean
réaliste que c'est peut-être un peu vrai
surtout quand elle se rappelle de
pourquoi wendell avait perdu sa bourse
de baseball mais aussi en se rappelant
d'un autre petit truc que wade elle lui
a dit à savoir qu'ils auraient un jour
mentionné une ancienne petite amie à lui
qui aurait réagi de manière excessive à
quelque chose qui l'aurait fait bref
jane veut prendre ses distances et elle
est aidée par un truc très efficace le
coc vide les cours deviennent virtuel et
pour économiser de l'argent elle décide
du coup de ne plus aller dans son
appartement à proximité de l'université
mais de retourner à la place vivre chez
ses parents dans sa ville natale
trois semaines plus tard jane se balade
sur un star et elle tombe sur la story
d'impôt taele story dans laquelle on
peut entendre en arrière-plan gwendal
chanter de l'opéra
petit bémol le pote de jane n'est pas
aux alentours de l'université il est
dans la ville natale de djen djen se dit
what the fuck mais elle se dit que c'est
très certainement le hasard que le coc
vide a fait bouger beaucoup de gens et
quand plus sa ville natale est pas si
loin que ça de l'université et c'est pas
non plus une toute petite ville le temps
passe et un jaune jane reçu un coup de
fil
ce coup de filet bien d'une amie à elle
qui est dans la même université et
surtout qui vient de la même ville
qu'elle au téléphone cet ami lui
explique qu'elle était en ville et qu'un
mendiant est venu lui poser des
questions sur jane elle a trouvé ça
celle où elle a donc décidé de l'appeler
immédiatement jane elle se dit mais
comment wendell peut savoir que cette
meuf est une amie à moi fins trop
bizarre et par la suite elle réalise
qu'en fait lors de sa visite en ville
son ami portait un sweat de lui
diversité wendell l'a reconnu et c'est
pour ça qu'il est venu lui parler de
jeunes là on se dit clairement ça fait
beaucoup et devinez quoi
jane se dit la même chose fin du
confinement jane retourne à l'université
mais cette fois il n'y a pas de sourire
de discussion ou de quelconques
interaction avec wendell elles ignorent
purement et simplement l a compris qu'un
truc n'allait pas et elles sont
éloignées
après ces examens il décide d'aller
passer un peu de temps chez son frère
qui était en colocation avec quelqu'un
mais qui est parti il ya donc un lit
tout frais tout vide dispo pour elle le
neuvième jour de ce voyage chez son
frère
quelqu un top à la porte vous savez qui
c'est son frère va lui ouvrir et après
avoir discuté pendant plus d'une minute
il retourne dans la maison et life ou
droit jane du regard jane comprend pas
ce qui se passe et son frère lui dis
papa et maman vont te tuer et son frère
continue il lui dit écoute moi aussi je
vais tuer c'est vraiment pas cool ce que
tu viens de faire
t'as même pas pensé à me demander alors
évidemment je t'aurais dit non mais tu
as quand même même pas osé me demande et
abuse jane elle comprend rien à ce qui
lui arrive et lui dit écoute frérot de
quoi tu parles
son frère continue de l'embrouillé il
lui dit écoute je suis papa pas j'suis
pas maman moi tu me sors pas de mensonge
le mec là il n'a pas simplement dit
qu'il était là pour sa petite amie il a
aussi donné ton nom des détails sur toi
et m'a expliqué vous vous étiez fâché
qu'il était là pour arranger les choses
et la jane comprend son coeur à rêve de
battre elle se lève l regard à travers
l'oeil de la porte et elle reconnaît
wendell il s'est douchée il s'est rasé
il a mis des vêtements propres
mais c'est bel et bien lui qui est là à
des centaines de kilomètres de
l'université devant la maison de son
frère
jane s'éloigne de la porte elle fond en
larmes elle s'assoit sur le canapé et
l'a immédiatement son frère comprendre
quelque chose va pas il retourne ouvrir
la porte et dia wendell ah bah écoute
frérot allait pas là désolé aléas plus
sans un mot wendell s'éloigne sauf qu'en
fait ils se dirigent vers la fenêtre de
la maison et une fois la fenêtre c'est
jane qui voit son canapé et la ivry il
frappe à la fenêtre en hurlant il parle
au frère de jane on lui disant que c'est
sa petite amie qui n'a pas le droit de
la garde et là dedans enfermés ils le
traitent de connard lui ordonnant de la
laisser sortir tout en essayant de
rassurer jane en lui disant qu'il arrive
et qui va l'aider à sortir de là et puis
après l'écrit un bruit weld elle vient
de mettre une gigue à droite dans la
fenêtre et de la traversée avec son gang
wendell perd énormément
et là il se met à insulter jane il lui
dit de regarder ce qu'elle vient de lui
faire qu'elle pourra rien faire contre
lui que c'est une le frère de
jane il est complètement choqué lui je
vous rappelle que de base il a juste
ouvert la porte à un inconnu et
quelqu'un vient travers sa fenêtre avec
son poing et wendell en hurlant retourne
devant la porte d'entrée et il se met à
la charge et le frère de jane évidemment
se mettre l'autre côté de la porte et la
tient jane fini par appeler la police
qui débarquent ils prennent wendell en
flagrant délit il était toujours en
train de bouillonner la porte et
finalement il se fait arrêter par la
police sans résister mais il expliqué à
la police que d'essayer de libérer sa
copine qui était prise en otage par son
frère et la police ne connaissant pas
l'histoire elle me note aussi le frère
de jane au cas où
lui se pète éditrice m'a menotté ensuite
excellent à l'issue d'une petite
discussion évidemment la police comprend
que le vrai problème c'était wendell est
pas le frère de jane donc elle relâche
le frère de jane et jane elle se
souvient d'un truc en particulier c'est
que pendant wendell se faisaient
escorter jusqu'à la voiture de police
menotté il s'est mis à chanter de
l'opéra et c'est ça qui l'a le plus
marqué est ce que tout le monde va bien
alors attention ce qu'il faut retenir de
cette histoire c'est pas ne parlait pas
au sdf n'est pas d'attention envers le
pas du tout c'est ce que jane dit elle
même c'est qu'elle s'est entêté à
vouloir continuer à entretenir une sorte
de relation avec wendell alors qu'il y
avait des tas de signes qui lui montrait
qu' il y avait de grandes chances que ça
parte en couille un moment où l'autre
est là sur l'échelle du ça part en
couilles elle s'est prise la peine
maximale jane la dernière histoire c'est
celle de thomas et elle est très récente
puisqu'elle vient tout juste de se
terminer
sachant qu'elle a commencé en février
2021 thomas vit à la campagne sa maison
elle est vraiment isolé à les coller à
une forêt et pour y accéder maintenant
il ya une route qui vient tout juste
d'être goudronnée en après-midi il est
devant la télé tranquillement et
quelqu'un toque à la porte
thomas va lui ouvrir et cette personne
se présente comme le garde forestier qui
lui explique qu'il a besoin de lui faire
signer un papier l'autorisant à abattre
un arbre qui se trouve pile entre le
terrain de la maison thomas et la forêt
qui elle appartient à la ville le gars
est normal il est propre sur lui donc
thomas le fait rentrer chez lui et lui
sert un verre d'eau is in ses papiers le
mec leur merci il part bref tout se
passe très bien
et puis une semaine plus tard thomas se
réveille en pleine nuit a causé un gros
bruit comme si un objet d'une taille
plutôt conséquente venait de tomber de
sa fenêtre
thomas et se demande ce que c'est mais
en même temps il a un peu la flemme
d'enquêté izik à 99% de chances pour que
ce soit un animal ou une branche d'un
arbre
bref il se rendort mais dans les jours
qui suivent il a des sensations cheveux
par exemple le matin quand il s'habille
il à la presse
son caleçon il a déjà été portée par
quelqu'un d'autre des fois ils rentrent
du travail et voit que les bouts de la
couette de son lit sont mis sous le
matelas sauf que thomas lui il met
jamais les coins de la couette sous le
matelas thomas comprend donc il ya
peut-être quelqu'un qui vient chez lui
quand il est pas là mais d'un autre côté
il en est pas sûr parce qu'il vient de
perdre sa mère ils expliquent ils dans
un état un peu de stress intense qu'il a
tendance à être un peu parano dans cet
état là et donc qui sait pas trop à quel
point ils doivent faire confiance ou pas
en plus de ça et ferme tout le temps
toutes les fenêtres et ya aucun signe
d'effraction quelconque au niveau des
portes ou des fenêtres fin tous en
nickel quoi qu'il en soit il veut en
avoir le coeur net il y en a marre
d'avoir le doute et donc il va inviter
un pote à vif chez lui pendant un petit
temps
le tout premier soir le pote de thomas
lui dit mec je crois qu'il ya bel et
bien un truc qui va pas chez toi j'ai
entendu des bruits pas dans le jardin et
j'ai vu une ombre
soit on est tous les deux parano soit il
se passe vraiment un truc bizarre dans
ta maison
étrangement thomas et vois plutôt ça
comme une bonne nouvelle il se dit ok je
suis pas fou il ya bel et bien un truc
bizarre ici et après une petite
réflexion il se dit ça doit être le
garde forestier
il est venu me faire signer des papiers
il ya deux mois pour abattre un arbre
sauf qu'il n'y a toujours aucun arbre
qui a été abattu et décide d'en avoir le
coeur net et donc ils seront à la mairie
pour discuter avec eux de cette affaire
d'abattage d'arbres
personne n'a jamais entendu parler de
cette affaire d'arbres thomas demande
donc à voir le garde forestier du
village parce qu'il ya bel et bien un
garde forestier et bingo c'est pas du
tout l'homme qui est venu sonner chez
thomas thomas sort de la mairie il est
évidemment choqué il se dit apte en fait
j'ai fait rentrer un mec chez moi qui
n'étais pas du tout la personne qu'ils
prétendent aide c'est grave il faut que
j'appelle la police là il va donc à la
gendarmerie est en chemin il appelle son
pote pour lui dire écoute frérot ya bel
et bien un mec qui vient des fois chez
moi je sais pas qui c'est donc dans le
doute et probablement en danger dégage
de là vient avec moi la gendarmerie ils
sont donc tous les deux à la gendarmerie
et les gendarmes prennent la sphère très
au sérieux et d'envoyer immédiatement
une équipe pour fouiller la maison et ce
avant tout et devinez quoi en arrivant
sur place ils tombent sur le faux gardes
forestiers
il se trouve que ce faux garde forestier
était en fait un détenu d'une prison
située à 20 km de chez thomas qui se
serait échappé il ya un peu plus d'un
mois il aurait pris trente ans de prison
pour avoir fait trois homicides et
d'usurpation d'identité pendant un mois
il s'est caché dans la forêt parce qu'il
s'est dit que c'était le meilleur moyen
pour pas être retrouvés et l'aurait
apparemment cibler la maison de thomas
parce que c'est la maison la plus isolée
de tout le périmètre
le fameux boom que thomas entendu
c'était juste lui qui prenait ses
marques autour de la maison etc avaient
sauté du premier étage
mais alors pourquoi il avait aucune
trace d'effraction pendant tous
et bien parce que ce faux gardes
forestiers quand il est allé chez thomas
il avait tout simplement volé l'une des
clefs de thomas qui se trouvait tout
exposé dans sa thomas précise que depuis
il a installé huit caméras et que ça lui
a coûté une couille mon gars c'est pour
ça que je ne vivrai déjà jamais à
proximité d'une forêt et encore moins à
proximité d'une prison d'accord c'est
vraiment ce que plus jeune moi j'étais à
anthony est juste à côté il ya un frêne
et je sais qu'un freigné une prison à
chaque fois on se faisait peur
avec mes potes en se disant ah il paraît
qu'un mec s'est échappé je sais pas quoi
faire gronder truc de gamin
thomas lui la sécu pour de vrai bref
c'est la fin de ce serait d'horreur je
crois qu'ils étaient longs j'en sais
rien je dis ça à chaque fois c'est
terrible j'espère que ça vous aura plus
en plus avec ses fins un peu précises et
détaillées je vous souhaite un excellent
été je suis fatigué je vais faire une
petite sieste qui ça intéresse ne
répondait pas ciao les busos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]